Warum der Schuster bei seinen Leisten bleiben soll und woher diese Rede kommt, erfahrt ihr hier. Als der berühmte griechische Maler Appelis eines seiner Bilder fertig gemalt hatte, stellte er treffendlich aus. Er versteckte sich in der Nähe von unbemänglichen Meinung der Betrachter zu erfahren. Ein Schuster meinte, auf dem Bild sei ein Schuh nicht richtig gemalt.
Die Kritik fand Appellis berechtigt, er korrigierte das Bild.
Am nächsten Tag kam der Schuster bieger, diesmal kritisierte er die Form der Beine, die
Kleidung und noch mehr.
Das liess sich Appellis nicht gefallen, hat aus seinem Versteck geboren und rief Schuster
über deinem Leisten ... Okay. Kann ich es nochmal hören? Ja, wir haben es nochmal. Warum der Schuster bei seinen Leisten bleiben soll und woher diese Rede wenn ihm kommt, erfahrt ihr hier. Als der berühmte griechische Maler Appelis eines seiner Bilder fertig gemalt hatte, stellte er öffentlich aus. Er versteckte sich in der Nähe um unbemängelnden Meinung der Betrachter zu erfahren. Ein Schuster meinte, auf dem Bild sei ein Schuh nicht richtig gemalt. Die Kritik fand Appellis berechtigt, er korrigierte das Wort. Am nächsten Tag kam der Schuster wie, ja diesmal kritisierte er die Form der Beine, die Bekleidung und noch mehr. Das liess sich Appellis nicht gefallen, war doch sein Versteck geborgen und rief Schuster dann über deinem Leisten. Anfordernd, damit man noch mehr davon hört. Das war Stefan Tietze. Und der, der jetzt da rum brabbelt und sich freut, dass er heute so ein bisschen kränklich klingt. Und ich hasse das ja, wenn Menschen so sind, dass sie sich dann so auf ihrer Krankenschimme ausruhen, nicht abhusten, sondern denken, in dem Kopf ist nämlich alles besser. Nach außen hin denkt man, ja, huste mal einfach jetzt mal ab. Innen drin, ich kenne das schon von mir selbst, klingt es gut, flotten will. Ich war letzte Woche krank, ich hätte diese Woche gesund sein können, aber ich habe mich dagegen entschieden. Ich bin die ganze Woche in nassen Socken rumgelaufen,
viel zu kalt. Alles für die Stimme. Alles für die Stimme, einfach nur, damit ich noch eine
Woche so eine herrliche, raue, mündliche Stimme haben kann. Alle Mailboxen wurden besprochen.
Mailboxen? Ich sag mal so, mit der Stimme wird die Mailbox zur Mädelbox. Das ist der Herrenpodcast. Der betont männliche Herrenpodcast, den ihr kennt. Der Stock und Wohne-Podcast mit Stefan und Florentin. Und ich bin zum Halsnassen-Ohren gegangen und habe Halsnassen-Ohren-Arzt gegangen und habe gesagt, können wir das einloggen irgendwie? Also können wir jetzt einfach mal so einen Abguss machen, sodass wir das einfach immer wieder hervorholen können. Machen Foto, knippst jetzt ein Foto, machen Röntgenfoto oder was auch immer hier richtige Lösung einfügen, Medical, Medical, Medical. Ich will jetzt meine Stimme einloggen. Genau, und so hätte ich es dann gern. Könnt ihr danach irgendwie fingieren. Ich meine, selbst an solchen krass empfindlichen Organen wie den Augen wird er herumoperiert mit laserscharfen Messern. So, und dann kann man doch einfach mal bestimmt den Rachenraum kann man doch auch besser machen. Aber ich habe auch mal vom Kollegen, du hast ja auch mal eine Stimmeveränderung durchgemacht, aber ein Freund hat auch mal eine Metamorphose durchgemacht. Irgendwie so eine Kehlkopf-OP, wie auch immer geartet, eigentlich eine Routinesache. Danach hat er anders gesprochen, hat mich irritiert. Ich bin auch wie so ein Hund oder so ein Alpaka und erkenne dann meinen Rudel nicht mehr und bin erst mal irritiert. Und dann habe ich auch den Kontakt abgebaut. Und seitdem haben wir lustigerweise, fiel es wirklich so, jetzt rückblickend so ein bisschen auf diesen Zeitraum dieser OP, habe ich den abgebrochen. Ja, ich habe auch in dieser Woche viele Leute kennengelernt und die kennen mich nur so, also wenn ich jetzt wieder normal gesund werde, dann sagen die, was ist das denn für eine, die kennen mich als Ronny, die kennen mich als Rennbahn-Ronny, ich bin ja auf der Rennbahn aufgewachsen, und so kenn ich die Leute. Welche Rennbahn, Pferderennbahn? Ne, Hunde, Hunde, Hunde,Rennbahn, erst Pferde und dann wurde das aber alles geändert, Hunde. Das ist billiger, sage ich immer. Wer ist auf 100 Metern schneller, Pferd oder Hund? Pferd. Und dann aber auf 200 ist der Hund schneller. Wer ist auf 300 Metern schneller? Dann wieder das Pferd. Der Pferd, Pferd. Das ist immer abwechselnd so, das sagen wir immer. Das ist im Blut, ne? Ja, das habe ich im Blut, das muss dir aber auch sagen. Also du gehst dann da hin und sagst, ich hätte gerne 400 Euro oder sowas, setz dich dann bitte auf hier Creme Royale oder sowas, wie die Hunde heißen. Grill Royale. Aber es ist ja so, ich muss ja dann, sag ich mal, wenn so ein Hund sich verletzt an der Rennbären, dann musst du ja da relativ schnell, sag ich mal, gar ausmachen. Ach so. Also das hat keinen Sinn. Und das war dann auch immer mein Job.
Also ich nehme mir dann den Hund, der so das arme Tier, das denkt, das hat gewonnen, irgendwie kriegt Sonderbär hier, irgendwie wird dann nochmal gestreichelt. So, dann gehe ich da in den Hinterraum und dann musst du, der Hund, der hat hier hinten so am Schädel, da hat der so richtig hier so, eine Schwachstelle, da hat der hier wie so einen Hut, also der Schädel, der geht hinten so ein Stück raus wie so ein Hut. und dann musst du da hinten in den Schädel reinpacken, so mit den Fingern,
und dann hebst du den Hund in die Luft, so am Nacken, und dann kannst du am Gewicht des Hundes, drehst du den so rum, so.
Ja, Herr Heinrichsen. Dann drehst du dich um und dann brichst du dem das Genick, das geht ganz schnell.
Ich hätte ja eigentlich gefragt, was sie zur Inflation sagen.
Was?
Ach, mach da keine Sorgen, das ist kein Problem. Aber ich sag dir eins, wenn der Hund, wenn du musst den richtig mit Schmackes nehmen, sonst geht das nicht schwer genug. Herr Heinrichsen, die Gaspreise. Und langfristig. Machen Ihnen die Gaspreise? Ja, ja, ja, nee, da mach ich mir keine Sorgen, du. Ich sag mal, ich wurde ja ordentlich bezahlt, nicht? Also das ist ja 100 Mark pro Hund war das damals. Da kommen die Leute ja zu dir und sagen... Sie haben die Hunde getötet und 100 Mark pro toten Hund bekommen? Ich hab die Kasse gemacht, ich habe die Kasse an der Rennbahn gemacht, ich habe aber auch die Hunde gemacht, so. Und dann musst du teilweise sogar mit zwei Hunden gleichzeitig, so, ne, also an jeder Hand ein Hund schön hinten den Nacken rein und dann drehst du den so und dann ist auch Schuss. Und dann ist natürlich die, ja, Rennbahn, man hört ja immer hier Untergrund und so, dann Gangster und Mafia und so, ne, nicht. Und das war ja auch damals in den 80ern, war das ja ein grosses Ding. Und dann kommt dann mal so ein Herz zu dir. Heinrich, haben die denn Angst vor dem Winter? Nee, da mache ich mir keine Sorgen. Kein Angst vor dem Winter. Aber pass auf, was machst du denn da? Da sitze ich dann da als 16-jähriger Steppke und dann kommt doch einer an und sagt, du pass mal auf hier, der Hund hier, der Crème Royale von den anderen, der habe ich gesehen, der humpelt, kannst du den nicht mal ausschalten? Dann sage ich mir, das ist in Ordnung, der hat doch vier Beine, der läuft doch so. Und dann ist klar, nee, die wollen ja die Konkurrenten ausschalten, und dann drückt ihr da so ein Herr, drückt ihr da mal so einen 500-Mark-Schein in die Hand, und was machst du dann? Sagst du dann, nee, kommt bald dein Geld, oder sagst du, ja, Mensch, du, da können wir uns um so ein bisschen einrichten, nicht? Ja, und dann sage ich mal, bin ich ganz ehrlich, dann rutscht man da auch so ein bisschen in die Kleinkriminalität rein, so, das ist ganz natürlich. Sie kommen ja eigentlich aus Hannover, das wundert mich jetzt, Sie wohnen seit zwei Wochen in Hamburg. Ja, richtig, das ist meine Perle, sage ich immer. Also, ich sage einfach mal so. Sagen Sie immer. Ja, nee, das sage ich immer. Sie haben bis vor zwei, ich glaube, zwei Monaten sogar noch eine Wohnung in Hannover gehabt. Ja, richtig, aber mein Onkel Willi, der ist ja alter Seemann, der hat mich dann hierher geholt. Und ich habe dann das erste Mal so eine richtige Sebestattung gesehen. Das ist was. Sprechen Sie schon Ihr Leben lang so? Naja, also es ist jetzt, ja, sag ich mal, man ist ja anpassungsfähig. Mein Onkel Willi hat immer gesagt, du musst sein wie ein Segel im Wind. Den haben wir nämlich auch interviewt und der hat gesagt, dass sie, seitdem sie krank war, nach einer Erkältung angefangen haben so zu sprechen. Davor perfektes Hochdeutsch. Der Willi, du, das ist Seemannsgarn, du, das ist Seemannsgarn. Der Willi, das ist ein Haudegen, sag ich dir, weil normalerweise, mittlerweile gibt es ja keine Seebestattung mehr, nicht? Mittlerweile machst du das ja alles an Land. Weißt du warum? Wegen meinem Onkel Willi. Man hat es immer primär am Land gemacht.
Nee, wegen meinem Onkel Willi, weil das ist ja so, der arbeitet ja, der ist ja angestellt bei der Reederei.
Und dann gibt es da immer, wenn du dann da im Unfall erleidest bei der Arbeit, dann kriegt ja deine Frau Rente und Witwen Geld und so.
Und dann hat der Willi gesagt, pass mal auf, ich sage jetzt einfach, ich bin unterwegs auf dem Kudde und dann gibt es hier einen Unfall und dann gibt es Sehbestattung. Und dann erzählen wir der Reederei, dass ich sehbestattet wurde. Wurde aber gar nicht, der war gar nicht tot. Und dann hat er weitergearbeitet und am anderen Namen, Billy hieß er dann, und dann hat die Frau trotzdem Witwingeld und Rente bekommen. Er er doppelt Geld bekommen. Ach, vom Vater Staat. Vom Vater Staat, das ist erst aufgefallen, als er auf einer anderen Beerdigung war und da war dann einer von der Reederei, der hat ihn erkannt so. Und seitdem haben die gesagt, das machen wir nicht mehr mit der Seebestattung, die müssen jetzt alle an Land bestattet werden, damit die Reederei sieht, dass da wirklich jemand im Sarg drin ist, weil sonst kannst du ja alles behaupten. Die See lügt nicht, sage ich immer. In dem Fall schon, das ist jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber in dem Fall schon. Und deswegen, wegen meinem Onkel Willi, der ist lebendig und tot gleichzeitig sozusagen. Schrödingers Willi. Ja, der Schrödingers Willi. Und das geht jetzt noch wochenlang so.
Daran müsst ihr euch gewöhnen.
Ich versuche immer weiter
von Florentin will wegzukommen und immer mehr
Rennmann Ronny zu werden.
Comedy-Person.
Ach ja.
Ich bin kein Fan von Dialekten und Akzenten,
primär weil ich es nicht kann.
Ich kann es nicht genau, die Trendschärfe
ist nicht vorhanden. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob was zuerst da war, meine Verachtung oder mein nicht vorhandenes Talent dafür. Manchmal hört man ins Wienerische rein, kommt dann auch nicht mehr raus, wenn man so so aus Spaß macht. Das ist immer das grösste Problem. Das ist das Problem, man kommt nicht aus. Manche kommen ihr Leben lang nicht aus Dialekten raus. Würdest du sagen, Akzente sind einfache Gags? Ja. Würdest du sagen, Dialekte sind einfache Gags? Ich würde sagen, Anschauungsbeispiel, die letzten zehn Minuten. Aber das ist gut. Vor allem, wir haben ja letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, über das Thema, kann man sich neue Dialekte ausdenken? Fiktive deutsche Dialekte. Ja, das war das grosse Thema der letzten Folge. Genau, das war sozusagen unsere Rede damals. Erstmal herzlich willkommen an die vielen neuen Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, die nach der letzten Folge reingekommen sind. Ja, letzte Woche war die viral Folge, die sehr zugängliche Folge. Wir analysieren Christina Stürmer, ich lebe. Da haben wir sehr viele neue Hörerinnen und Hörer gewonnen. Hallo an der Stelle. Aber ganz interessant an dem Punkt finde ich ja auch, dass es ja sozusagen verlorene Dialekte gibt. Also ich sag mal so, ganz wertfrei, ganz wertfrei, ganz wertfrei, ganz wertfrei, ganz wertfrei, ganz wertfrei, ganz wertfrei, Deutschland war ja früher mal ja grösser, genau, wert, völlig wertfrei, ich sag nicht, dass, du machst es auf eine Art wertvoll, nein, nein, ich sag nicht, dass das gut ist oder schlecht, ich hab das einfach als historischen Fakt genannt. Es wäre wertfreier gewesen, wenn du einfach drüber hinweggegangen wärst. Ich wollte aber sagen, gut. Je mehr du dich distanzierst von dem, okay. Und da in diesen Gebieten gab es ja Dialekte, die es jetzt einfach nicht mehr gibt. Polnisch. Die sind weg. Du willst behaupten, dass polnisch und mein deutscher Dialekt war. Jetzt müssen wir da doch ein paar Fragen angehen, die ich unbeantwortet gelassen haben wollte. Und da gibt es ja zum Beispiel den Klassiker, den Klassiker-Sketch zum Thema Dialekte sind leichte Gagte. Peter Frankenfeld, die Legende. Ich hole dich wieder raus, ich ziehe dich wieder raus. Peter Frankenfeld, die Legende, der ja mal so einen Wetterbericht in allen verschiedenen Dialekten gemacht hat.
Und da, das ist so alt, dass es da noch ein Gebiet gab, das es heute nicht mehr gibt. Und da hören wir für unsere Ohren einen deutschen Dialekt, der fiktiv klingt, den wir nicht kennen. Wir hören mal rein. Achtung. Erbarmung, was haben wir in Königsberg?
Ein Wettchen? Na, wenn ich Ihnen sage, also wir haben keinen Sandsturm, nuscht nicht, nein, nein, wir haben nuscht, keine Springflut, kein Gefrie und so nuscht, das ist ein richtiges Pomuchelskopfwetter, richtig, ja.
Also ich weiss nicht, wir reden oft, liebes Wetter, aber zur Zeit, man weiss gar nicht, worüber man überhaupt noch reden soll.
Königsberg. Jetzt geht es mit Leipzig weiter, das kennt man. Da sind alle beide Mundwinkel, die Florentin dann doch besetzt, hochgeschnellt, weil er wieder etwas kannte. Na klar, aber ein Patient, den ich kenne, haha. Aber ganz spannend, dass wir hier zwei deutsche Dialekte haben, die wir nicht mehr als solches erkennen. Königsberg und Breslau. Mhm. Ja, ich habe ja immer durch diesen DNA-Test, den ich gemacht habe, gelernt, dass eine Familienteil von mir von da kommt und die haben wahrscheinlich so gesprochen. Aber also der ist einfach verschwunden, oder? Ich meine, die Leute, die ja gelebt haben, da sind ja auch dann viele zurückgekehrt und dann ist er aber einfach weg. Oder ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es noch irgendwo Leute, die so sprechen oder so. Meinst du nicht, du könntest dich da mit deinen Wurzeln nochmal verbinden und das nochmal rausholen und so sprechen? Ich glaube nicht, dass die Wurzeln da, ich glaube, die Wurzeln sind da weggewurzelt, die haben sich weggeschlichen. Aber das ist jetzt zum Beispiel ein Fall von einem verlorenen Dialekt, der ist komplett weg. Der ist komplett weg, ja gut. Sprachen verschwinden, tauchen neue auf. Dafür haben wir jetzt solche Wörter wie Macher und Bodenlos und Sue und Gommemode. Hör auf, Rückfragen zu stellen. Stell keine Rückfragen. Okay, sorry, Entschuldigung. Es ist jetzt uncool, Rückfragen zu stellen. Das ist die Jugendkultur. Rückfragen sind so Boomer-Cringe. Merkwürdige Positionen in dieser Jugend. Schwierig. Ja, aber ist doch gut, aber vielleicht wird es auch mal wieder in. Vielleicht gibt es irgendwann mal Rapper, so Rapper, also ich glaube Rapper haben es sehr schwer, weil die müssen sich ja immer abheben von dem, was davor kam, aber neue Sachen sich ausdenken ist nicht leicht. Abheben aber nicht abheben, ne? Genau, vielleicht ist es eine Möglichkeit, auch mal in diese alten Dialekte reinzugehen. Vielleicht ist das eine Möglichkeit. Ist vielleicht eine Möglichkeit. Ja, und wenn man von jemandem auf Hip-Hop-Tipps hören sollte, dann wahrscheinlich von dir. Aber deine Neustimme hilft in der Hinsicht ein bisschen. Ja, keine Ahnung, es ist spannend, aber es spricht sehr im Sprachen auch so, entstehen aber neue Dialekte eher nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl, eher verschwindet noch mehr. Naja, aktuell ist Deutschland ja recht klein. Also historisch einfach mal als Fakt. Also du kannst einfach fest, wertfrei. Nein, du sagst wertfrei, aber du sagst es nicht wertfrei. Doch, ich sag es wertfrei. Du guckst mich kopfschüttelnd mit verschränkten Armen an und sagst, Deutschland sei ja recht klein. Im historischen Vergleich. Ich meine nur, dass... Ich sag doch nicht, dass es wieder losgehen soll. Du bräuchtest halt diesen Appendix mit wertfrei nicht, wenn du davor dir einfach mal Mühe geben würdest, es wertfrei zu sagen. So, mehr sag ich ja nicht. Ich sag nur eins, wenn du neue Dialekte willst, es gibt einen Weg. Okay? Ich möchte nur... Stefan, nein. Immer fordern, fordern, fordern.
Ich habe nur gesagt, ich beobachte eher eine Abwendung vom...
Du bist das beste Beispiel.
Weh, wag es nicht, mich als Beispiel anzuführen.
Du bist schon drin.
Ey, dann stelle ich eine Rückfrage.
Wenn du mich als... Das kann ich gar nicht leiden.
Wenn du eine Rückfrage stellst, bist du...
Gen Z hast es, als Beispiel herangezogen zu werden.
Dann wirst du eine Fussnote.
Ich will nur sagen, du hast dich von deinem bayerischen Dialekt abgewendet. Weg. Und das finde ich spannend. Klar kommt es vielleicht aus so einer pubertären, du weißt, eine Rabauke, so einer pubertären Abwendung vom Elternhaus oder keine Ahnung, da gibt es ja dann schon so Momente, wo man einfach mal sagt, nee, das habe ich eigentlich auch gehabt. Ich wollte dann auch noch in Köln, hier spricht man ja lupenreines Hochdeutsch, und ich wollte hier nicht als der Ruhrpottler, der ich dann ja doch war, auffallen und musste mich dann hart zusammenreißen. Das war eine schwierige Zeit. Ja, ich will mir meinen eigenen Dialekt bauen. Es hat noch nicht so wirklich Fuß gefasst. Nee, aber deswegen meine ich, es fällt doch eher auf, dass man sich von den hauseigenen Dialekten abwendet, oder nicht? Man sieht in Großstädte zum Studieren und da spricht man dann eher Hochdeutsch. Man will nicht unbedingt. Und vielleicht kommt es dann irgendwann im Alter wieder. Ich habe dann auch irgendwann so gedacht, ja, warum muss ich mich hier so verstellen? Ich habe eine Charade gespielt. Ich wollte Dortmund verstellen. Du warst Two-Face quasi. Ich war Two-Face. Du hattest zwei Herzen Schlugen in deiner Brust. Ich war Two-Face mit zwei sehr ähnlichen, zugegebenermaßen sehr ähnlichen Gesichtshelten. Die Stunde Autofahrt. War gut fürs Make-Up-Departement. Das war eine Scharade. Das ging wenig. Also bevor du Quattro-Face warst, aber halt Quattro-Stefani, aber vier sehr ähnliche Sachen. Deswegen möchte ich hier sagen, das Versteckspiel ist vorbei. Es ist vorbei. Ich komme aus der Ecke von Dortmund. Das ist eine Stunde Autofahrt entfernt. Jetzt ist es vorbei. Jetzt ist das Versteckspiel endlich vorbei. Hätte man bei Quattro Stazioni nicht auch ein bisschen unterschiedlichere Stazioni nehmen können, als einfach vier verschiedene Käsesorten? Nee. Stagioni. Ach, Entschuldigung, es gibt Quattro Formaggi
und es gibt Quattro Stagioni.
Und Stagioni ist genau das, was ich will,
für unterschiedliche. Aber sind die
normiert, die Stagioni?
Gibt's vier
klassische Stagioni?
Ich glaube, man hört das gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Also Pizza für Jahreszeiten ist ...
Na, das ist ja primavera. Nein, nein. Eine Pizza für Jahreszeiten ist italienisch, Pizza alle Quadro Stagioni, ist nach italienischer Traditione, eine Pizza, die zu jedem, die einem Viertel unterschiedlich belegt ist, um die vier Jahreszeiten Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter darzustellen. Ach, das wusste ich gar nicht. Jetzt hör mal zu, die Pizza für Jahreszeiten besteht oft aus ähnlichen Zutaten, die aber, die auch für eine Pizza Capriccio-Rosa üblich sind. Tomaten, Mozzarella beziehungsweise Parmesan, Basilikum, Pilze, Artischocken, gekochter Schinken, Oliven, Öl, die Zutaten könnten aber auch variieren. Es gibt keine Normbelegung. Es gibt vier Varianten in der Normbelegung. Es gibt Sardellenfilets und grüne Oliven, vorgebrachte Miesmuscheln ohne Schale, Kochschinken, Mozzarella, Babyartischöcken und Schwarze Oliven. Mir ist die immer zu experimentell. Das heißt aber mehr als vier. Vier Stück. Mit jeweils einem und getrennt. Also es ist nicht wie die Pücklerschnitte, wo du immer Schokolade, Erdbeer, Vanille hast, ist Quattro Stagioni offen. Es ist nicht festgegeben. Es wird aber häufig in den Minüsia schon auch definiert. Das heißt, es ist meistens keine Wundertüte. Erwartet aber, klassisch, Pilze, Schinken, Artischocken und Paprika. Paprika? Ja, die vier Jahre seit. Die waren ja... Moment, was ist Winter? Offensichtlich Schinken. Und was ist Sommer? Ganz offensichtlich Pilze. Frühling? Artischocken. Und dann bleibt Herbst für Paprika. Ja gut, jetzt ist auch die Frage, wo. Man merkt nach der zweiten Zutre, dass man sich komplett verrannt hat, weil man weiß, was übergeblieben ist und man denkt, es passt doch hier dann vorne nicht zusammen. Okay, dann lass uns doch mal die Top-Vier-Stagioni machen, oder? Die Top-Vier-Stagioni. Ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, Platz Nummer vier, die Oliven mag ich nicht so gerne auf Pizza, muss ich sagen. Mein Platz vier sind die Miesmuscheln. Ich bin kein Fan von Miesmuscheln, ich bin gar kein Fan von Muscheln. Viel Knabberei, für wenig Ertrag, viel Fummelei, Händestinken nach Fisch und also da ist ja dann dort lieber ein schöner Scampi-Spieß. Finde ich aber gut, dass in der Aufzeichnung dabei stand, Muscheln ohne Schale. Das ist nett, das ist gut, dann muss ich die nicht runterzwängen. Bei mir sind auf drei allerdings die Muscheln. Ich bin ein Muschelfan. Ich bin ein Muschelmann. So sehr, dass sie auf Platz drei gelangt werden. Bring mir die Muscheln ein. I only eat clams. I'm a clam guy. I'm a clam guy. I'm a classic clam guy. The C-C-G-G. So, auf Platz... Die Früchte des Meeres, sage ich immer. Drei ist bei mir Baby-Artischocken. Oh, okay. Warum denn die Baby-Artischocken?
Nein, nein, nein, die sind super.
Mach doch wenigstens die richtigen.
Nein, nein, die Adult, die ab 18.
Ich will die Adult-Artischocken.
Nee, die sind bei mir auf zwei, die Artischocken.
Ich will die R-rated, kompletten, nackten Artischocken auf meiner Pizza.
Die Artischocken sind bei mir auf zwei. Wir haben die gleiche Liste, nur um eins versetzt.
Heißt, ich muss eine Zutat erfinden.
Ja, wir wissen es alle. Liebe nichts mehr als Lachen, das den Husten übergeht. Das ist das Schönste. Ja, voll. So richtig schmerzverzerrten Gesicht. Ein Freund hat das, der, ich weiß nicht, ist vielleicht so ein Asthma ausfugst oder so, weil der hustet und dann, der lacht ganz doll über meine Witze, freue ich mich doll drüber, dann wird's husten und das Husten lenkt ihn so sehr vom Witz ab, dass er ihn danach wieder ganz ernst anguckt. Weißt du? Also dieses und man ist aber noch in dieser Lachstimmung, aber er hat durch diesen furchtbaren Husten zwischendurch. Er hat so ein Reset bekommen durch das Husten. Ja, aber das ist immer so schwierig, weil man ist sofort aus der Stimmung raus.
Es ist schwer, so einen Flow eines Gesprächs aufrechtzuerhalten.
Und es ist, als würde er den nächsten Witz erwarten direkt.
Ah, das ist ja bitter.
Er guckt einen an wie so ein amerikanisches Late-Night-Publikum, weißt du, was lacht.
Gibt mir Spaß.
Und dann so vorbei mit dem Lachen, alle still und warten auf den nächsten Witz.
Ja.
So ist er auch. Erwartungshaltung. Erwartungshaltung. Gibt mir Spaß. Gibt mir Spaß, ich will Spaß. Platz eins, Paprika. Auf jeden Fall. Ich liebe Paprika auf Pizza. Ich habe auch lange experimentiert. Hasse Paprika. Ja, ich nicht. Bei mir ist es eben anders. Ich habe auch lange experimentiert, weil ich habe mir mal irgendwie eingebildet, dass man karamellisieren kann. Und dann dachte ich, ich bin ultraschlau und haue auf meine Pizza, Tiefkühlpizza, noch Paprika drauf, geschnitten und darauf Zucker und das haue ich dann in den Ofen. Das klappt wahrscheinlich nicht, weil das nicht heiß genug ist, um zu karamellisieren. Aber ich glaube, ich habe wirklich einige Male schlicht einfach gezuckerte Paprika auf Pizza gegessen und habe mich super schlau gefühlt. Dir war die Tiefkühlpizza nicht süss genug, es war nicht ungesund genug. Ich baue jetzt noch mehr ein, um meinen Körper zu schaden. Der Körper, das Gesundheitsministerium Körper guckt zu und denkt sich, Pizza, oh, er hat Paprika dabei, oh, er hat die Paprika dabei, okay, okay, Leute, alles gut, alles gut. Was macht er denn jetzt? Er hat eine Zuckertüte in der Hand. Moment mal, hä, das ist doch Quatsch. Der räumt die auf. Der räumt die auf. Der räumt die auf, kein Problem. Er wird die wegschmeissen. Die ist abgelaufen. Ja, die ist abgelaufen. Zucker ist hat sehr kurze Haltbarkeit. Das wollten wir übrigens auch nochmal sagen. Das müssen wir eben dringend irgendwie mitteilen, durch irgendeinen Ausschlag oder so. Er schmeißt einen Brief in die Nervenbahn. Alles gleich, ich schmeiß einen rein.
Jungs! Moment mal, der kippt jetzt Zucker auf die Pizza? Das kann doch nicht fucking ernst sein! Was ist das Scheißproblem? Was haben wir ihm getan? Was haben wir ihm getan? Insulin? Ja, Chef! Träges Insulin. Wir brauchen dich. Okay! Insulin, man! Stell dir vor, er ist so blau-gelb angezogen, grossen gelben Stiefeln und auf seiner Brust thront ein grosses I. Das aussieht wie ein ungerätes Fragezeichen, ungerätes Ausrufezeichen. Ja, genau so wie man es erwartet. Ein Blau-gelb ist das Farbschema für ... Also mein Insulinman ist keine Überraschung. Insulinman ist, was man erwartet. Er ist ein normaler Mitarbeiter auch dort. Er hat sich halt wie gesagt dieses Cape angezogen. Das blaue Cape flattert im Wind, flattert in den Damenwinden. Sehr ungesund auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich als Jünglicher so schlank sein konnte bei dieser Art von Ernährung. Ich war auch nie richtig, richtig schlank. Er hatte selten eine richtig schlanke Phase und habe es nicht gemacht.
Also alles scheißegal, alles Schall und Rauch.
Informationen haben keine Bedeutung.
Okay, das ist deine These. Fakten und Wissenschaft hat keine Bedeutung.
Alles wabert und fliesst und ist zu komplex.
Am Ende ist alles zu komplex, um es überhaupt irgendwie zu verstehen, also warum versuchen. Hunde machen das auch nicht. Und guck, wie sie florieren. Alle haben Hund. Willst du auch ein Hund? Du hattest Zugang zu dem Hund. Um eine Ecke habe ich jetzt quasi einen Hund. Eine Person, mit der ich Zeit verbringen, einen Hund. Und dadurch habe ich jetzt auch quasi einen Hund. Und es ist sehr beruhigend. Tatsächlich hätte ich es auch nicht gedacht. Ich kam nie aus einer Familie, die das gelernt hat, also so eine Tierfamilie, die einem Tiernähe und so nahegebracht hat. Und bin jetzt selber sehr überrascht, was das mit einem macht. Also du bist zu weniger zynisch geworden, weil du weniger zynisch geworden, weil du warst ja sonst eigentlich ein sehr ablehnender Mensch. Ich blicke jetzt in den Ernst der Welt. Ich bin sehr ein liebender Mensch geworden, ein sehr loyaler Mensch geworden und weniger zynisch. Stört sich nicht, dass der Hund genau so ist, weil der so gebaut wurde und gezüchtet wurde, wie er sein soll? Dass diese Liebe, die du bekommst, einfach einprogrammiert ist in ihn, weil alle, die das nicht hatten, wurden erschossen? Was ich beobachte, ist ja, der Hund muss ja erzogen werden. Und alles, was man dem wegerzieht, sind Hundedinge. Das heißt, wohin du den erziehst, basically, und ich glaube, das ist die Zukunft von Haustieren, ist, du machst den zu einem gefügigen Roboter. Und mehr wie ein Mensch eigentlich, oder? Nein, das nicht unbedingt. Du willst ja trotzdem Hundeeigenschaften, aber du willst alles Wilde, Instinktive weghaben. Der soll nicht rumrennen, wenn du das nicht willst. Der soll im Prinzip nichts machen, wenn du es nicht willst. Der Trend müsste doch eigentlich gehen, und ich glaube, das ist doch irgendwann billiger herzustellen, so ein Boston Dynamic Dingenskelett, da brauchst du dann so ein schönes Fell rum, kannst ja hier, weiss ich nicht, im Museum, Naturkonomuseum Berlin können die ja super dieses Aussending präparieren und so, ist ja auch Hund umbringen und da einfach ein Roboter reinstecken. Reinstecken, genau, ja, das machen die ja weiss ich auch. Und dann läuft der rum und dann bist du im Restaurant, da willst du nicht, dass der rumstreunert, sondern dann sagst, dann drückst du auf den, dann sagst einfach, vielleicht kann der ja auch da mit seinen Augen, was lesen, dann machst du den Finger hoch und sagst Sitz oder Platz und der macht Platz und fährt dann so ein und kommt erst wieder mit, wenn du, das ist ja, die Zukunft ist, glaube ich, Androide, Hunde, Haustiere, die du kaufst, weil das willst du ja. Der soll kuscheln, wenn du das willst.
Ja, aber der kann dann halt keine Leichen finden und so, ne?
Das wäre für mich der einzige Grund, einen Hund zu haben, ist, ich würde dem irgendwas richtig Hartes antrainieren, so richtig so einen Skill, so dass er wirklich Drogen finden kann, Bomben finden kann, Leichen finden kann, sowas. Weil ich meine, ich weiss auch nicht, wie das bei Hunden ist, die dann denken die so, oh nein, also ist das so wie eine Art Ferien und wenn dann die was suchen müssen, ist das deren Job und so. Und die sagen, oh Gott, bitte bring mir nicht sowas bei, irgendwie, das ist wie so eine Berufsaufbildung und der andere denkt sich, oh, ich bin lieber Entrepreneur und bin eher so Junggeselle alleine unterwegs. Ich glaube, ich würde, weil kann man die nicht einfach ausbilden, dass die Geld suchen oder so Also, ich meine, es gibt Affen, die ausgebildet sind, um zu klauen.
Die werden ausgebildet, um einfach Leuten Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen.
Und dann bringen die das irgendwo hin. Mit dem Terrorismusfallen.
Ja, genau. Und dann bringen die das irgendwie zu so einem Hauptaffen oder sowas.
Und der dealt dann mit den Menschen und so.
Oh, so wie du, ich wär so gern wie du.
Ich möchte gehen wie du, stehen wie du, ich will so gern wie du, ich möchte gehen wie du, stehen wie du, uuuu. Und der hat dann nur so einen Unterhändler unter den Menschen und kauft dann ganz viele Bananen. Also King Louis is a pyramid scheme. Ja. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Wir hätten darauf kommen können, weil er in so einer Pyramid lebt. Warum ist er so gut drauf? Die Zeichen waren da. Ja, warum
ist er so gut drauf?
Arbeitet aber nicht, er hat Leute, die für ihn arbeiten.
Ist gar nicht so gut drauf.
King Louis will doch gehen wie du,
stehen wie du.
Er möchte, also in seiner Lyrik
ist doch die Antwort zu seinem Leid.
Ich bin leider ein bisschen verwirrt, weil ich habe
König der Löwen schon lange nicht mehr gesehen,
stattdessen schaue ich immer diese Dingo, diese deutschen Dingo-Filme an, diese Zeichentrickfilme, die schlechte Imitate von Disney-Filmen sind. Grandios, schaut euch die gerne an. Auch auf YouTube findet man da viele Dingo-Pictures und da gibt es Aladdin und da gibt es die Mäuse-Polizei und die sind wirklich Feinster-Trash, also wirklich großartig, ganz furchtbare, ganz unnachvollziehbare Handlungen, manchmal Lieder, manchmal nicht, dann gibt es ein paar Songs, die immer wiederholt werden, auch die man dann auch aus Aladin kennt und dann aber auch in König der Löwen drin sind, wo die keinen Sinn ergeben, ganz, ganz wild. Also Feinster-Trash. Feinster-Trash, ganz, ganz wilde Fahrt. Feinster, unironisch hergestellter Trash, das ist nämlich auch wichtig. Ja genau, das ist ganz wichtig und ich sag mal so, vielleicht gibt es da Kontakt auch mit Erben des Dingo, weil es gibt Erben von Dingo und es gibt auch unveröffentlichte Filme und es gibt ganz grosse Geheimnisse. Es gibt auch eine grosse Anhängerschaft in den USA, die das alles aufsaugen und das archivieren und so, das ist ein grosses Ding. Und es ist eine spannende Welt auf jeden Fall. Ich habe es wirklich hergelesen, weil was ich bei diesem kleinen Hund beobachte, ist, immer wenn ich pfeife oder singe, legt er seinen Kopf schief und schaut mich an. Und da habe ich gerade mal gegoogelt, warum man das macht. Das beobachtet man ja häufig bei Hunden, dass wenn irgendwas passiert, dann machen sie, dann legen sie den Hund so auf, sagen wir mal, 45 Grad in den Kopf, auf 45 Grad. Und ich habe gelesen, dass sie das machen, damit sie mehr Informationen aus deinem Gesicht bekommen. Also sie wollen, dann verstehen sie etwas nicht, sie verstehen, sie können nicht ganz gänzlich dein Gesicht lesen, was das gerade soll, Wir wollen aber alle Informationen, die dein Gesicht, das menschliche Gesicht gibt, weil Menschen sind Gesichtswesen. Wir geben alle Informationen über Stimmung und etc. über Gesicht ab, Hunde ja gar nicht. Hunde ja auch viel über Gerüche, Pheromone und halt Schwanz wedelt und so, also Körpersprache. Wir alles nur über das Gesicht, während wir immer einfach nur dastehen mit unseren langen Schlabber Armen, die an uns herunterhängen. Und er starrt immer nur die Arme an, denkt sich, wackelt der jetzt, was macht der da und da passiert gar nichts, gibt ihm nichts. So, und dann legt er den Kopf zur Seite, weil denen die Schnauze im Weg ist, streng genommen. Die können gar nicht so ins Gesicht gucken, die können gar nicht so in unsere Gesichter gucken, weil die schauen an ihrer Schnauze vorbei. Stell dir das mal vor, stell dir mal vor, du hast eine lange, mach mal mit deinen, mit zwei Fäusten eine Hundeschnauze, Die ist im Weg. Guck mal, das guckt man mich an. Ja, ja. Das ist doch im Weg. Aber ist die zwischen den Augen oder unter den Augen? Die Schnauze. Die haben auch die Schnauze, die Augen sind wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen weiter rechts und links. Naja, es ist dem jedenfalls im Weg und er legt es quer, damit er zumindest mit einem Auge mein ganzes Gesicht checkt. Aber das klappt doch nicht. Das ist doch wie wenn man bei Counter-Strike versucht, um die Ecke zu gucken, indem man sich so bewegt bei Videospielen.
Das klappt doch nicht. Der Hund hat doch die Schnauz immer noch im Gesicht.
Aber finde ich eine interessante Beobachtung.
Er schiebt die aus dem Weg, damit er zumindest ein Auge mein ganzes Gesicht angucken kann.
Verstehst du? Das geht schon.
Ach so.
Genau, also zumindest ein Auge.
Es geht dann eher um die Rotation. Das sind okay. ein Auge, okay. Genau, weil er mehr Informationen braucht. Wenn ich pfeife, braucht er mehr Informationen. Er ist das einzige Lebewesen in meinem Leben, was mehr Informationen von mir will, wenn ich pfeife. Alle anderen drehen sich eher weg, weil sie weniger Informationen haben wollen. Weniger Stefan, weniger Stefan, wohingegen eher mehr. Aber es ist spannend, dass der Hund auf einen Sinn zurückgreifen muss, den er gar nicht oft benutzt. Also Sehen ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so ein Ding für den und plötzlich muss er alles auf Sehen machen und denkt sich, ich bin dafür überhaupt nicht ausgestattet. Diese riesige Nase, diese riesigen Ohren und jetzt will der Augen. Das ist komisch. Die sehen auch komisch, die sehen auch komisch. Aber es ist auch Dominanz, dass wir den Hund zwingen, seinen wahrscheinlich am schlechtesten ausgebildeten Sinn zu benutzen, wenn wir weiterhin unsere besten Sinne benutzen. Weil wenn der sagt, lass uns mal über Grüche kommunizieren, mein Freund, dann stünden wir aber ganz schlecht da. Ist es nur nicht mein, ich sehe den Fehler nicht bei mir, bin ich ganz ehrlich, weil ich singe ja und pfeife ja. Der Sehsinn ist doch auch einfach der beste Sinn. Sorry, natürlich argumentiere ich jetzt aus einer menschlichen, anthropozentristischen Perspektive heraus, aber ganz objektiv auf der grossen Tierliste. Wir können ja Top 5 Sinne machen, können wir gerne machen. Haben wir schon mal gemacht und ich glaube, es hat sich bei mir verändert. Aber der Sehsinn ist der beste Sinn. Ich konnte zwei Wochen lang, halt dein, hier werde ich langsam ausfallen, weil... Laber mich nicht voll! Halt dein Dummes mal! Nee, als erstes würde ich sagen, ich singe ja und pfeife ja für sein Gehör. Was kann ich denn dafür, wenn er das so wenig zu schätzen weiß, dass er mehr Informationen aus meinem Gesicht saugen will? Er könnte die Augen zumachen. Du meinst, er sollte sensibler zuhören. Er legt so die Pfoten hinter die Ohren. Ich finde, er sollte seine Ohren aufrichten, sollte sich hinlegen, Augen zumachen. Und du. Und der Hund so, Moment mal, was ist da los? Was ist da los? Was sagt er da? Genau, und da sollte er den Klängen genießen, anstatt mich schreck anzugucken, um aus meinem Gesicht meine Emotionen lesen zu wollen. Was ist denn dann der beste Sinn, wenn ich sehe? So, auf jeden Fall, und ich fasse sie zusammen, weil zusammengehören, auch hier gibt es verschiedene Lager, ich fasse sie zusammen, weil zusammengehören, schmecken und riechen sind der beste, äh, sorry, sorry, tu mir leid, hören, dann schmecken und riechen, dann sehen. Warum fassst du die denn zusammen? Ach so, schmecken und riechen fassst du zusammen, hören ist der beste Sinn? Hören ist auf jeden Fall der beste Sinn. Ach Quatsch, Maulwurf? Hören glaube ich ganz gut, der sieht halt nix. Was ist denn ein Tier, das nicht hören kann? Schlangen können Hören, glaube ich, ist gut, ehrlich gesagt. Der sieht halt nix.
Was ist, was denn ein Tier das nicht hören kann?
Schlangen können nicht hören, glaube ich.
Also, ich finde, hören, finde ich, ich habe lange lange darüber nachgedacht, als ich zwei Wochen lang nicht schmecken konnte, habe ich lange darüber nachgedacht und nicht riechen konnte, dementsprechend auch gehört das zusammen, habe ich lange darüber nachgedacht, cool, und bin zum Schluss gekommen, dass mir Hören auch wichtiger ist als Sehen. Hören, wenn keine Musik mehr in meinem Leben wäre, kannst du mich gleich niederstecken. Ja, was mit Beethoven, der hat auch nichts gehört und trotzdem noch Musik gemacht. Ja, weil er... Der hat das ja auch gehört irgendwie. Nein, der hat es nicht gehört, der hat einfach nur ein perfektes, der Perfect Pitch. Doch, der hat das schon auch gehört, glaube ich. Also du kannst dir Dinge auch im Kopf hören, die du nicht mit den Ohren hörst. Du kannst ja jetzt einen Song auch in deinem Kopf abspielen, ohne dass deine Ohren irgendwas machen. Ich glaube, es kommt darauf, wie du das bewertest, weil... Also ich habe sehr viele tolle Streits in meinem Freundeskreis gehabt über diese These meinerseits. Weil es kam viele... Es gab eine Lager, die haben gesagt, ja, kann ich komplett nachvollziehen, siehe ich genauso, und das andere Lager, ja, ihr verarscht uns doch gerade. Das sagt ihr jetzt nur, um cooler zu sein oder so, weil natürlich ist Sehen der beste Sinn. Ja, die finde ich sympathisch, kannst du mir diese Art von Freunden von dir mal vorstellen. Mit denen hätte ich gerne. Zudem habe ich keinen Kontakt mehr. Oh, okay. Brauchen die neuen Freunden? Als, als es hiess, in Corona-Zeit haben sich Familien gespalten und Freundeskreise gespalten, habe ich lange angenommen wegen dieser Sinnessache. Nicht naiver Stefanlein. Deutschland ist gespalten, es polarisiert sich immer mehr. Ja, wegen den Sinnendingen, oder? Ich habe gesagt, ja klar, verstehe ich. Also bei uns war das Gleiche. Kein Corona-Leugner dabei, aber viele Hörleugner dabei. Also ich finde das, ja, für mich ist die Sache klar. Aber es hat doll polarisiert. Und ich glaube, es läuft daraus hinaus, kannst du dir besser vorstellen, in deinem Kopf, in deinem Schädelchen, kannst du dir besser etwas visuell oder auditiv vorstellen? Kannst du dir auditiv besser vorstellen, sagst du sehen, ist dein best Sinn. Was andere kannst du ersetzen. Genau. Das heißt, dass ich eigentlich besser hören kann, weil du kannst es dir besser vorstellen. Vielleicht kannst du dir Beethoven besser vorstellen. Aber wenn ich doch eher bereit bin, hören zu opfern, kann ich mir auditive Dinge besser vorstellen, hast du doch gerade gesagt. Das, was du bereit bist zu opfern, kannst du dir besser vorstellen. Also kann ich als See-Fanatiker, kann mir besser Klang vorstellen. Genau. Und du als Hör-Afficionado kannst dir besser Bilder vorstellen. Ja, ich kann mir noch besser Bilder vorstellen als zwölf Minuten den dritten Satz von Beethovens Fünfter. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Schöne Bilder kann sich auch vorstellen. Christina Stürmer, denn sie hat ein tolles Lied geschrieben und wir möchten dieses Thema beenden, denn... Nee, jetzt kommt Teil zwei. Ihr alle wollte das und jetzt kommt Teil zwei. Letzte Woche haben wir über Ich lebe gesprochen und es gab einige Fragen zur Interpretation, ganz viele Texteilen, die in unseren Augen nicht wirklich Sinn ergeben. Du bist das Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Was soll das heißen? Na ja, haben wir geklärt. Gift, unklar. Du bist das Gift, doch das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich, mich, ja. Sei es wertfreier. Wir haben uns natürlich gefragt, was bedeutet das? Und wir mussten uns an die Experten des Landes richten und natürlich die Experten sind in solchen Fällen Deutschlehrer. Deutschschüler. Allerdings hatten wir keinen Zugang dazu. Und zwar, Schulportal hat dieses Lied angeboten als
Schulaufgabe für die achte Klasse.
Interpretieren Sie doch bitte dieses Lied.
Und da fragt sich mal jemand, warum wir hier in Deutschland
Bildungsprobleme bekommen. Da fragt sich noch
mal einer. Wenn man ich lebe,
als die Speerspitze
deutscher Popmusik,
Popmusik hält, Popschutz, funktioniert auch super.
Wenn ich das Wort sage und es funktioniert nicht. Toll. Oh Scheiße. Stefan, wir kommen da schnell durch, okay, macht dir keine Sorgen. Und ich habe aufgerufen zum Verrat. Ich habe gesagt, Lehrer des Landes, vereint euch und brecht euren Berufseid. Brecht euer Schweigen. Brecht euer Schweigen und gebt mir Zugang zu den Lösungen. Denn Schulportal.de ist natürlich eine stark belagerte Seite, weil alle Schüler natürlich die Lösungen haben wollen, unbedingt. Deswegen gibt es da ganz, ganz hohe Schutzwelle, die das verteidigen sollen, Welle, durch die ich auch nicht durchgekommen bin. Aber es gibt einige Lehrerinnen und Lehrer da draußen, die nehmen ihre Berufswelle ehren nicht so sagen wir mal so. Wälle, durch die du mit deinen stümpfen Waffen auch nicht durchgekommen bist. Ne, überhaupt nicht. Deine stümpfe Waffe war, na, ich denke mir, Schule aus, bei der ich unterrichtet. Als Herr Meierling. Und wir haben einige Lösungen zugeschickt bekommen von Lehrern. Das heißt, ihr seid Verräter. Ich habe sämtliche Namen aller Verräter ans Kultusministerium weitergeleitet. wir werden darüber auch nicht reden. Ich wollte einfach nur die schwarzen Schafe rausfiltern und ich hoffe, ich habe der Allgemeinheit damit was Gutes getan.
So, nein, wir haben das Ganze bekommen, Klasse 8, Klassenarbeit.
Klasse 8.
Klasse 8, ja, ist es formuliert, einen Einleitungssatz unter Berücksichtigung von Titel, Textart, Interpret, Album, veröffentlicht ja.
Und Thema, der Love Song Ich lebe von Christina aus dem Album Schwarz-Weiss, welches im Jahr 2005 veröffentlicht wurde, thematisiert eine scheinbar einseitige Liebe, die Schönes mit sich bringt, aber auch Gefahren in sich birgt. Das ist also eine Kurzzusammenfassung des Ganzen. So, jetzt... Wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt schon weiter als letzte Woche, weil so klar haben wir es auch nie auf den Punkt gekommen. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Wir haben natürlich das Grundthema des Songs schon grob verstanden, toxische Liebe, aber wie die einzelnen Metaphern da reinpassen, das haben wir nicht ganz verstanden, wie die zu deuten sind. Und ich möchte es kurz machen, darauf wird nicht eingegangen. Nee, es wird in der Lösung nicht darauf eingegangen, auf jede einzelne Textseile. Es geht nur um ein paar Stilmittel und es geht darum, das Ganze so ein bisschen zu beschreiben. Ehrlich gesagt konnte ich aus dieser Lösung gar nicht so viel rausholen. Aber zum Beispiel heißt es hier, Aufgabe vier, die Stilmittel. Hier gibt es zum Beispiel eine Lösung, schmeckst bitter süss, ist eine Antithese. Die Liebe des lyrischen Ichs zum lyrischen Du ist süss positiv, hat aber gleichzeitig auch negative Seiten bitter. Eine Antithese, süss bitter, ein Kontrast. Oder ein Vergleich Du saugst mich aus wie ein Vampir. Das Gefühl, wir machen Rückschritte in dieser Folge, aber okay, wir waren schon mal weiter. Das lyrische Du raubt dem lyrischen Ich alle Kräfte, beziehungsweise Aufmerksamkeit. Das lyrische Ich kann nur noch als lyrisches Du denken. Lyrisches Du finde ich aber auch eine interessante Formulierung. Das lyrische Ich kann nur als lyrisches Du denken? Ja. Belege? Keine. Okay. Dann gibt es noch eine Metapher. Ich lebe, weil du mein Atem bist. Das lyrische Du ist für das lyrische Ich enorm wichtig, lebenswichtig, ohne Atem kann man nicht leben. So, und jetzt haben wir hier. Du bist das Gift, doch das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich. Vers 16 folgend. Und zwar ist das eine Metapher. Okay, ja okay, ich habe das Gefühl, so weit waren wir schon. Erklärung. Das lyrische Du tut dem lyrischen Ich nicht gut. In Klammern Gift. Andererseits tut es dem lyrischen Ich auch nicht gut, auf das lyrische Du zu verzichten. In Klammern, das Gegengift hilft auch nicht. Nee, aber das ist ja Bullshit. Das Gegengift hilft auch nicht. Wirkt gegen mich, hilft auch nicht, ist schon ein großer Unterschied, liebe Lösung. Ja, das ist jetzt nämlich die Frage. Nee, das ist keine Frage. Das ist nicht damit gemeint. Das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich, bedeutet nicht, dass das Gegengift nicht hilft. Und vor allem, andererseits tut es dem lyrischen Ich auch nicht gut, auf das lyrische Du zu verzichten. Sprich, wenn das Gegengift wirken würde, wäre das nicht gut, das ist aber nicht gesagt. Das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich. Hier wird die Lösung schwammig. Hier wird die Lösung wirklich schwammig. Ist es sogar härter. Also die Lösung ist für mich, ich glaube, unterm Strich ist es ein Popsong. Wir wollen zu viel, wir verlangen zu viel von dem Popsong, Fragezeichen, vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht sollte Popmusik auch ein bisschen mehr leisten können als das. Es ist nicht so einfach wie in der Kurzzusammenfassung von Trueportal.de beschrieben, eine Liebe, die mal gut, mal schlecht ist und beide Seiten und so. Nein, es ist viel toxischer als das. Und das Gegengift wirkt gegen mich, heisst ja, dass es sogar schlecht für sie ist. Ja, ich bin da auch nicht zufrieden. Und zwar hatten wir auch noch die Sachen mit dem Du bist verliebt, wie schön für dich, warum sagst du es nie, haben wir hier bei Aufgabe 5 die angesprochenen Beziehungen. Das lyrische Du offenbart dem lyrischen Ich nicht seine Gefühle, Du bist verliebt, wie schön für dich, warum sagst du es nie, auch da wird nicht näher darauf eingegangen. Alles in allem ist das in meinen Augen sehr oberflächlich, diese Lösung, auf die wahren Probleme des Songs wird hier nicht eingegangen. Ja gut, aber jetzt was willst du auch von einer Gedichtsanalyse, den Lösungen einer Gedichtsanalyse verlangen? Da kann ja jetzt nicht die Lösung drinstehen. Es ist ja auch immer noch Kunst. Und jetzt ist natürlich Aufgabe sieben interessant, was ist die Moral des Ganzen? Was ist die Botschaft? Welche Intention steckt dahinter? Und zwar, die Intention verfolgt zum Beispiel, Menschen darauf aufzufordern, ihrem Partner ihre Gefühle auch mitzuteilen, die Grösse einer Liebe zu erkennen und sich auch Gefahren einer Liebe bewusst zu sein. Das ist die Botschaft des Ganzen. Dafür hätte man vier Punkte bekommen. Sei müde, wenn ich dein Kissen bin. Sei durstig. Ist ja nicht die schlechte Seite deiner Liebe, es ist einfach eine furchtbare Abhängigkeit, in der du verlangst, dass Individuen kürzer treten, dass Individuen fallen lassen. Ja, es ist schwierig. Schade, dass sie nicht auf diesen Du bist Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht Satz eingegangen sind, der für mich noch der merkwürdigste ist. Es ist auf jeden Fall schwierig. Ich habe mittlerweile übrigens auch auf Instagram, auf der Story, gegenübergestellt die verschiedenen Versionen des Textes, dass einmal Du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält und die Welt, wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Christina Stürmer hatte sich zum Aufnahmezeitpunkt noch nicht geäußert. Bei Redaktionsschluss, der sehr früh ist, immer bei uns, da hat sich Christina Stürmer noch nicht so geäußert.
Wir wissen also nicht, welche Textfassung die echte ist, welche Textfassung vielleicht korrigiert wurde, wo man auf Kritik Rücksicht genommen hat, wissen wir alles nicht, Christina Stürmer schweigt.
Ein ohrenbetäubendes Schweigen.
Du! Das war eine Antithese. Ja, du schweigst! Doch dein Schweigen ist zu laut für mich. Doch wenn das Schweigen bricht, wirkt gegen mich. Ist ja scheissegal. Es ist ja mit der Zeile, die auch grammatikalisch keinen Sinn ergibt, alles scheissegal. Doch dein Schweigen verstößt gegen die Lärmschutzverordnung. Ja, du kannst, das ist leicht, an die Thesen. Aber ich finde das toll, ich finde das gut, dass Schülern sowas beigebracht wird, dass man auch klar unterscheidet, was ist lyrisches Ich, was ist die Sängerin, wo ist der Unterschied? Aber man kann sagen, dass Schulportal.de sich jetzt nicht kritisch dem Texten überäußert, in der Inkohärenz und dem vielleicht auch eher schwachen Metaphern, sondern sagt eher, wofür steht das, was erklärt das und so. Es gibt jetzt keine, wie findest du das, also keine, ja keine Frage zum kritischen Äußern. Ich glaube, das ist dann Schritt zwei, Schritt eins ist immer analysieren und was ist dann und ein paar Jahre später kann man dann sagen, jetzt kritisiert das mal.
Aber interessant, ja, aber wirklich echt schwach.
Ich fand es spannend, dass so die Lösung von der Schulaufgabe aussieht, wo man...
Also ich weiß auch nicht, wem das auch helfen soll, weil das sind ja relativ offensichtliche Dinge, aber gut.
Das ist ein Vergleich. Wenn man das so abklappert, ist es wahrscheinlich hilfreich für die Korrektur. Ein Vergleich. Das bin ich so albern. Achte Klasse und ein Wie kennzeichnet einen Vergleich. Na ja gut. Na ja gut, wir sind ja auch ein bisschen älter, ne? Es ist okay, das ist ja auch nicht für uns, wir sind nicht die Zielgruppe dieser Frage. Ja, vielen Dank.
Siebenundfünfzig Punkte hätte es hier gegeben für diese Prüfung. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele wir davon bekommen haben. Vielleicht kann ja auch ein Lehrer oder eine Lehrerin mal korrigieren. Habt ihr so einen Quatsch mal gemacht, so einen Quatschtext analysiert? Boah, das weiß ich nicht mehr, aber ich glaube schon, also bestimmt. Wir hatten, ähm, wir hatten Tekia! Habe ich noch eins bekommen. Das glaube ich. Wir hatten den R.E.M.-Song, haben wir in Englischunterricht durchgemacht. Das weiß ich noch. It's the end of the world as we know it. Den Text hatten wir analysiert. Und der ist nicht so einfach zu analysieren. Aber das war auch nicht achte Klasse. Da war ich schon in der Zehn bestimmt. Da haben wir den Text von Ari Em. Das könnt ihr ja mal machen. Schreibt uns doch mal, ich bereite so einen kleinen Lösungs-Sheet vor, und ihr analysiert mir mal, Ari Em's It's the End of the World as we know it. Oh, das ist gar nicht so leicht. Ich glaube, viele sind auch wirklich schwer zu interpretieren, einfach weil man sich wahrscheinlich auch viel im Reim, also in diesem Metrum da bewegen muss und dann krümmt man manchmal Worte so hin, die dann halt passen, dann sagt man Welt und nicht Gefängnis und dann ergibt es plötzlich keinen Sinn mehr, aber man denkt sich vielleicht, fuck it. Vor allem erfolgreicher ein Künstler, eine Künstlerin, ich weiß nicht, wie Christina Stimme, war das ihr Break ihr Breakthrough-Hit? Ich glaube, ja. 2005 war ihr Jahr oder 2003. Ich habe auch unterschiedliche Daten dazu gefunden, tatsächlich. Okay. Naja, weil ich habe gedacht, also je erfolgreicher ein Künstler, eine Künstlerin, desto weniger fordert man ja auch ein, ein Second Draft. Das heißt, es ist oft der erste Entwurf, den man da präsentiert bekommt. Ja. Wenn man jetzt nicht einen wahnsinnig selbstkritischen Künstler, Künstlerin vor sich hat. Ari M wird ja den Text geschrieben haben, so die haben eine coole Musik, hier ich mache dieses Riff und dann schreiben wir darauf einen Text. Weißt du, worauf ich Lust hätte eigentlich? Der erste Entwurf. Eine Textinterpretation von dem Binky Sagtagt-Boo-Song. Meinst du nicht, wir können da auch mal ins Reimschema reingucken, rein lunzen? Ich glaube, dass unsere Band nicht die Komplexität hatte, es nicht so der Komplexität geschafft hat, dass man jetzt hier eine Analyse machen könnte. Ich meine, ich kann natürlich auch ein paar eigene Werke vorlegen.
Ich habe ja in meiner Schulzeit auch Gedichte geschrieben.
Ich habe vorher sie geschrieben.
Ja, Der Wecker zum Beispiel.
Der Wecker?
Der Wecker von Florentin Will.
Ah, ich glaube es nicht. So früh und doch so spät. Zu spät.
Panik.
War es in etwa das?
Nee, warte mal, ich glaube, ich kriege das sogar noch zusammen.
Der Wecker von Florentin Will.
Das war zum Sonntag. Es hat wieder die Glocken im Hintergrund.
Okay, sorry. Wir hören nun Deutschland mit der Stadt Nummer 14 beim Poesie-Song-Contest, Eurovision-Poesie-Contest, EPC, Florentin Will.
Es ist wirklich spannend, wie er den Vorentscheid für sich entscheiden konnte.
Mit reiner Gedächtniskraft steht er auf der Bühne und kann sich anscheinend nicht ganz erinnern. Aber jetzt freuen wir uns auf Florentin Will mit Der Wecker. Der Wecker. Du musst uns täglich stören, bist kaum zu überhören. Überall hört man, nee. Okay, das hat nicht so gut funktioniert. Wir hoffen, das nächstes Jahr vielleicht ... Warte mal. Überall hört man das Stöhnen? Ja, brauchst du mir nicht fragen. Ich konnte noch nie so wenig helfen. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, noch mal, noch mal. Ja. Du musst uns täglich stören, bist kaum zu überhören. Überall hört man das Stöhnen, sagen wir mal, wenn du mal was verpasst. Und dann kommt schon das Ende. Wenn du, ich fasse jetzt mal zusammen, ich paraphrasiere, wenn du klingelst, werde ich wild, du bist der Rahmen in meinem Lebensbild. Achso, okay. Ich kann mich nur in die letzte Zeile erinnern, den Rest musste ich jetzt ein bisschen... Aber da gibt es zumindest mehr zu analysieren, als wo ist denn unsere Bildung hin, ohne die macht das Leben keinen Sinn, die Binky Sack-Buh-Logik macht da, ich glaube, da ist nicht so viel, nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu analysieren. Ich werde heute noch, Ich werde heute noch richtig tiefe Lieder singen.
Ich muss das heute noch mal machen.
Du musst ein bisschen tiefe Lieder singen.
Sixteen Tons.
Ich will, dass du dich mal ausruhst.
Hi.
Du schaffst, du bist, du arbeitest zu viel. Bis die Mountains, high to Dungeons deep and caverns old. Schaust du die neue Herr der Ringe Serie? Das mache ich heute den ganzen Tag, glaube ich. Schaust du die neue Serie? Hier, ich schau sie stets und auch ganz gern.
Findest du, dass die vierte Folge eher schwach war? Ich hab sie nicht ganz verstanden, doch nur hin, jeden Sonntag spreche ich mit Anton und Mara. Wir besprechen das jede Woche, die neue Folge. Also falls ihr wirklich wissen wollt, was ich dazu sage, wir besprechen das ausgiebig, das sind absolute Tolkien-Experten, Mara und Anton von Rockabins TV, die können das immer so ein bisschen einordnen, ich habe da gar keine Ahnung davon. Cool, dass du so Werbung für andere Format haben musst. Ich stehe kommenden Sonntag am Obi in Köln-Ernfeld und er lacht nicht und mache eine Autogrammstunde und stelle mich da hin und spreche mit Bobby, dem Maskottchen von Obi. Wie heißt der wirklich, Bobby? Nein, weiss nicht. Das ist ein Bieber von Obi, das ist ein super Name, Bobby. Bobby, Bobby. Das ist richtig gut. Obi klingt halt schon wie ein Maskottchen, muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen. Ja, Ibo. Nee, cool, gucke ich mal rein. Ich bin gespannt, was du zur Folge sagst. Ich gucke die auch sehr gerne, habe sehr viel Spaß bei der Serie und bin einfach gerne in der Welt zuhauen. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann nicht mehr folgen. Das ist mein Hauptproblem. Aber ich tue mir oft schwer mit Plots. Und mit Grammatik. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich Geschichten überhaupt mag. Das ist dann oft so, ich schaue so einen Film und denke mir so, ich verstehe das die anderen Leute, dann so, ah, das war so krass, weil der hat ja bemerkt, dass sie den Schlüssel schon hatte. Und deswegen konnte er dann feststellen, dass sie ja eigentlich die gewesen sein musste, wo er nur den Schatten gesehen hat am Anfang. Und deswegen wusste er die ganze Zeit schon, dass sie es war, bevor sie es ihm gesagt hat, eigentlich so, ah ja. Es war so krass, wie er sie gedoublecrossed hat, wo er die ganze Zeit einen Schritt vorausus war und ich war mir, ja genau, so bist du auch in der Mitte. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Und ich einfach den ganzen Film nur so, woher kenne ich das Lied? Ich glaube, du, das ist unsere Analyse von Ich lebe, ist da vielleicht ganz sinnbildlich. Du hängst dich manchmal vielleicht an so Details auf, wie das Gegengift wird gegen mich und verlässt das große Ganze. Wenn man dich dann fragt, worum geht's bei Christina Stürmers, ich lebe, würdest du eher sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, um Gift, ich würde sagen, um Toxikologie. Ich meine, du verstehst ja alles bis dahin, du hängst ja nur an dieser um Tox, um Biochemie, es geht klassisch um Biochemie. Aber ja, mir geht's auch so, ich habe dann vergessen auch Dinge und so, aber ich habe auch Spaß beim Hinterherrennen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ja, ja. Hui, oh, sorry. Ich bin da schon gern dabei und gern in der Welt zu Hause und so und dann sollen die dann mal wieder einen Hobbit-Song singen und dann bin ich doch dabei. Ich muss auch sagen, ich mag immer den Anfang von Filmen wesentlich mehr als Mittelteil und Ende. Ich würde mir lieber drei Anfänge von Filmen anschauen als das warst jetzt aber du. Ich warst gerade, glaube ich. Das war's jetzt aber du, mein Lieber. Ja, okay, Jesus. Ich würde lieber drei Anfänge von Filmen sehen als einen ganzen Film. Ich schau lieber Anfänge so. Spider-Man, zack, hat seine Kräfte. Wie geht er damit um, wie kommt er damit klar, versteckt das, wer weiss es und so. Wir werden's nie erfahren, wir gucken nur den Anfang. Würdest du lieber drei Anfänge gucken oder fünf Enden?
Boah, drei Anfänge auf jeden Fall.
Enden mag ich am wenigsten.
Da kippt es, da würde ich dann lieber auf die Enden gehen.
Würdest du lieber drei Anfänge von schlechten Filmen gucken, als drei Enden von guten Filmen?
Nee, drei Anfänge von schlechten Filmen.
Weil das Gute ist ja, der Anfang ist ja immer gut.
Denn Zuschauer geht ja immer wohlwollend rein.
I don't know about that. Doch, glaube ich schon. Ich mir sehr, sehr. Ich glaube nicht. Doch, ich glaube nicht. Weil der Zuschauer geht ja immer wohlwollend rein mit einem, okay, krass, was passiert hier. Das geht auch nicht. Ja, doch, ich glaube nicht. Und ich glaube, man kann einen Film erst nach 15 Minuten schlecht finden. Davor darf man nicht. Das ist so, man guckt ja erst mal, was passiert. Wer dich vielleicht bambuselt, vielleicht ist es ja alles anders, vielleicht tut der Film ja nur so und dann ist aber doch alles anders, dann sind die doch gar nicht im Weltraum, sondern nur in einem Studio oder und so weiter und so weiter. Das sind alles Ameisen eigentlich, die träumen und wachen auf und ah, ich bin eine Ameise und dann geht es eigentlich in der Ameisenwelt erst richtig. Ist schon auch ein selbstbewusstes Medium, ne? Also Film, wenn man im Kino sitzt, es ist schon sehr fucking selbstbewusst.
Wir machen das Licht aus, oder?
Wir machen das Licht aus, damit ihr nichts anderes machen könnt. Was soll das Licht ausmachen? Es gibt seit Jahrzehnten zwei Snacks, die ihr wählen könnt, Nachos oder Popcorn, yeah! So, und dann ist das Licht aus, und dann kommt halt dieses Paramount oder so Columbia Pictures, und das alles mit diesen Statuen, und es ist wie so, weißt du, es hat so ein Selbstbewusstsein, so einen brachialen, archaischen Charakter. Ich sag, ihr kommt nur einen Film zu sehen, hier ist noch Werbung. Genau, hier ist noch Werbung. Weil ihr wollt den Film so unbedingt sehen. Wir können es uns erlauben, wir sind ein Theater. Wir können alles machen, weil ihr werdet alles tun, nur um diesen fucking Film zu sehen, weil ihr wollt ihn unbedingt sehen. Und deswegen, das sind glaube ich diese 15 Minuten, die das Genre an sich schon,
The Medium is the Message, erkauft,
die man dann eh immer gut findet, da hast du schon recht.
Und ich finde auch, er sagt, viel einfacher immer so,
wie man Dinge auf die Reise setzt, easy,
und danach wird's schwer.
Und dann zusammenzuknüpfen ist dann immer schwierig.
Ja, SWN sind oft Quatsch, quatschig.
Tenet, kompletter Quatsch.
Versteht niemand.
Gut, bei Tenet war jetzt auch streng genommen das Ende der Anfang.
Fuck this movie.
Okay, da würde ich dann lieber das Ende sehen als den Anfang, das stimmt.
Sehr guter Tweet, den ich gelesen habe, Stephans Tweet Week.
Stephans Tweet Week!
Zwei, zwei, einmal.
Eins, eins, zwei, zwei.
Der eine Tweet war, ich paraphrasiere auf Englisch, weil da ist mir einfacher fällt jetzt zu paraphrasieren, weil es mir nicht mehr einfach mehr war, da war es noch so warm, da gab es diese Hitzewelle draußen in den USA und dann If we were in Tannit, it would be cold outside or something, fuck this movie, fuck the weather. Diesen Tweet fand ich sehr gut, Super, ja. Or something, fuck this movie, fuck the weather.
Und einen zweiten Tweet, den ich gerne vorstellen möchte, kommt dieser Woche von einem anderen Nutzer.
Eine Null-Aussage.
Und zwar folgender Tweet.
Mickey is a nickname, and nicknames are for friends, and I'm not friends with Michael Maus. Ah, sehr schön. Den fand ich sehr gut. Da habe ich bestimmt einen Tag lang drüber gelacht und allen Leuten erzählt. Ja. Das kann man aber auch bei ganz vielen Namen machen. I'm not friends with William Gates. Kannst du auch machen, einfach so. And I'm not friends. I'm not friends with Leonard Kravitz. Lenny is a nickname, a nickname of our friends. And I'm not friends with Leonard B. Kravitz. Leonard Bartholomew, Bartholomew, Kravitz, Bartholomew. Oh Mann, dass es immer noch so gute Witze gibtus. Wie lange, Michael Maus. Er kriegt direkt so eine Seriosität. Michael Maus spricht auch nicht so hoch. Ja, nee. Michael Maus ist ernst. Michael Maus ist ernst, hat einen Job und fucking Probleme. Der hat Steuern zu zahlen und jetzt kommt diese Rückzahlung nicht. Es ist alles scheiße. Und seine Frau Michaela Maus. Das ist grossartig.
Mann, ey, wie lange gibt es jetzt schon Witze?
Und trotzdem gibt es noch neue. Sei
doch froh. Ich freue mich noch.
Ich empfehle jetzt jede Woche meinen Lieblings-Tweet,
das ist auch eine lustige Rubrik. Wir kriegen
Lacher und haben nichts dafür getan.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche.
Haut rein, geniesst es. Vielen, vielen Dank
an alle Verräter unter der Lehrerschaft in
Deutschland, dass sie uns geholfen haben. Vielen, vielen Dank. Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.